[Musique]
ovo bienvenue chez son boss qui a pas
d'écart est allé à l'eau souvent
le marel mourouvin sophie j'ai 30 ans ça
fait bientôt un an que j'ai créé
l'entreprise on bosse à cette multi
alors avant que l'entreprise j'étais au
chômage j'avais envie de d'indépendance
de créer
un emploi pour moi aussi j'étais
accompagné par pôle emploi puis j'ai
fait une demande de taz aussi avec la
chambre des métiers et maintenant c'est
la boutique de gestion que monsieur pour
avoir chez tous les saints pour débuter
mon activité en fête à schaffen matériel
est là pour acheter et c'est tout
pour le local aussi on a eu l'occasion
de la demande avec la mairie il a
programmé deux ans et demi à cordes à -1
et comporte
une entreprise 100 most c'est une
entreprise familiale
un clin d'oeil à nos origines de
madagascar c'est pour ça le nom son most
parce que la bannière peu ça me semble
pas comme ça en fait été de génération
en génération
maman a toujours fait comme ça et elle
n'a pas pu avoir sa propre petite
boutique c'est une troisième
transmission etc les recettes de maman
samba sy propose tout ce qui dit
apéritif local compliment ça moussanais
m'enfin si baigner sais mais c'est hier
à rodez petite touche de nouveauté aussi
en proposant les hamburgers
inévitable avec le la crise due dans ce
moment c'est pourtant fait la venue de
l'autre amour dans la literie on fait
face au mans avec moi ou c'est messenger
ou par des votes et puis nos fils avec
des personnes la davie gurs et de
délivrer chaud
comme ça l'a toujours été de nous te une
tradition à rayonner faux papiers sont
pour coiffer être la tradition locale
alors cette différence yann hodé d abord
de nous sommes ça c'est l'originalité
d'être peu trop chez nous des saveurs
comme crevettes papaye pertre citronnée
saad vraiment rond pendant très
longtemps fait que ben nous on pense
qu'on est parti ça on s'en doute là
constamment récemment seul doigt depuis
voyage pour quatre soirs ils sont des
places un havrais de manioc du cannet
sur neuf rajel pommes de terre morue la
fascine tous les fumées cheuva keynes a
dit
celle en a plein toutes les maisons de
la pâte aux épices au tout tout tout
tout est maison et utilise des produits
total que pour durer et du halal aussi
capable et moss a essayé car gros
poisson est d'être sûr et à abidjan
comme ça sur un appel à aller fonds
spécial la poupée et à la fin un bon
appétit